hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I have something very very
exciting it is a very very special treat
now I posted this on Twitter a while ago
this hot mess this is basically blast I
don't know ten eleven years of my
digital life and all of you guys were
like hit up lioness lioness helper she
needs help
well guess what is in here a hundred and
fifty terabytes of storage we are gonna
go from that to just this oh my goodness
this is very I'm setting this out I'm
with these things these are so expensive
I know but I'd always travel so I would
just like to edit right off of these
little guys and then every time they
would get fool I wouldn't know what to
do with them I mean it's great they're
designed by Neil Bolton which is amazing
Neil great guy and this isn't even the
worst because over here
there's another one this is basically 16
terabytes from the past I don't know a
few months and then I edit off of these
little guys these are two terabyte
solid-state drives which basically these
are all the videos that I haven't edited
yet and so these are all full and then
when this gets full I start panicking
and then I start taking some files from
here and then putting them over to here
but then I'm not sure if I put them on
this one and then everything just starts
getting really crazy and then my
computer is full and then I start
absolutely getting the shakes right now
what is your strategy for redundancy
well sometimes if it's really important
I save it twice on this Drive and then
I'm here hurt no no this is automated
okay mind you I'm pretty tech savvy but
when it comes to creating servers and
all of that I don't really have any idea
what we're doing let's take a step back
don't I need two steps back I think we
can put this anywhere where you have a
network plug okay and a power plug
that's all I mean so the ethernet goes
to my router yes okay or any one of
these so where do these guys cat6 that's
awesome you have cats expiring in here
yeah bored of the go I actually have an
absolutely no idea where that goes okay
let's go find your mechanical room
where's your hot water heater looking
for hot water heater it's just it's just
a place where it would be likely that
all these things would gather I'm not
actually looking
the hot water oh we don't need the hot
water heater for the server you know
okay how do you feel about on Lego oh me
too
I would assume it'd be in here right you
just come prepared with the screwdriver
yeah of course
don't you always carry screwdriver you
know I carry knives
this is awesome great you are wired up
with you have cat6 up the wazoo in this
place so if I asked you you know do you
know where all of these go
no so what are we trying to figure out
where we can put your storage server
hmm okay with some networking Rika
jiggery which would be relatively
inexpensive okay like maybe a you know
$30 which your solid shopping no big
deal yes stopping anywhere where you
have one of these jacks in the house was
that for a high-five yeah no they're not
Laye not labeled okay no there's one
more here oh I mean they're they're all
over the place I'm pretty sure there's
one back here so you could be running
all this stuff wired instead of Wireless
just like I don't know my server room
why did they put it way up on the wall I
think probably for the TV Oh
every room has the ethernet and this one
is up on the wall for a TV why was this
house to suck this was made for me no
way there's not gonna be one of the
bathroom there is one in my other
bathroom oh where would you be expected
to put this television yeah well I think
if anybody's gonna figure it out I think
I'm gonna have to have a bathroom TV you
know I don't think I want in the closet
oh wait I know it's on the wall again
let's go find another this house is
bizarre okay well we already know
there's one here so this there's another
one I lost out so maybe you could sit
very nicely in that corner yes
but what table management wise you're
gonna have to come down the wall over
there oh yeah we'll use the one done
okay I have never seen anything like
this this is actually really crazy
because like I've never really paid
attention to it all right so I'm just
gonna kind of tuck it there you know
here I'll make it easier to work on
didn't make any assumptions about your
your networking capabilities and I
brought a switch yes but it's only eight
port so it's actually not even big
enough for this crazy place so we're
gonna have to go get a switch but what I
didn't bring and this is a bit of a long
shot a VGA cable and a VGA capable
monitor do you have a chance do you need
some amiibo no okay cuz you can't have
that okay I found a monitor so one of
the things 45 drives does is they can
powdercoat any color you want and they
can do pretty much any graphic you want
now you may have noticed that this is
sort of ugly I didn't want to say that
but it's definitely not a good look
[Music]
beautiful so I'm gonna quickly swap that
out so so perfect let's do this first
okay then let's throw all the drives in
it then we'll go shopping deal this is
the best day of my life alright what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna set it up so that
if one of your drives did happen to fail
all the data is intact so if one drive
fails yes it's still everything's okay
so just take it out you send it to
Seagate they've got free data recovery
service on these iron wolf Pro drives
and then you just pop in a new one and
it automatically rebuilds the data that
was now that's crazy so how does it do
that magic do you want the technical
explanation I think we do yes if you
would like to give it to us it's a
method of storing data called parity and
what it does is it uses a calculation
kind of like the sum of that bit on all
the other drives to calculate some
parity
a bit so then if you were to lose a
drive it's like an algebraic equation if
this Plus this Plus this Plus this
equals this and if this is missing and
we have everything else then we can just
rebuild it that's pretty awesome and I
was that something specific to this
whole system the way that it's handled
in this system through unbraid is pretty
special because most raids will have
requirements like if you wanted to
expand your storage you have to buy like
chunks of eight drives at a time whereas
with on raid you just pop in a new one
anytime you want more storage that's
amazing and I do have a pair of side
cutters side cutters Clippers oh it's
got a drill and a charger for the drill
and a battery for the drill it's still
me original package it's kind of like
pliers I know what you're talking like a
little bit a little yeah a little pinchy
there little pinchy pliers have cuticle
cutters this may work I don't know what
a cuticle cutter is now you do some kind
of personal grooming items this was
basically all I had to do that's it this
is the perfect tool oh my god
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so kind of a long shot do you still
have the box that the big server came in
that was a long time ago yeah I kept
everything in here though I'm actually
I'm missing some screws I don't think
you would find that box in this closet
sorry this fell behind my friends is
busy dress of course you have a Princess
Daisy dress it's a really good thing you
showed me this before we went to Best
Buy
the SSDs so we're gonna run them in raid
one which means you've got one terabyte
of solid-state storage and we just have
to get Network stuff okay y'all mr.
Kingston Tina we're legit on our way out
the door to go buy FSF hey I'm glad you
found these okay I still don't have
screws though I'm gonna put these
somewhere safe and not behind a bunch of
Daisy dresses be parents it's only one
Daisy dress the other is Princess Peach
is this like those weird spider-man Elsa
videos
so printers we're getting into like
we're getting into like pouring stop
flames so that's good but now we're
getting into Power Bars
we need good we need the most compact
one well that's real good yeah this
looks pretty good this is an $18 cable
these things are worth like one dollar
that is brutal I really feel like we're
heading the wrong way though cuz like
all the IT stuff is over there and this
is like toys and drones and games this
would do everything in your house mm-hmm
a very successful best buy trip I feel
like this has turned into a reality show
yeah got a network switches like pimp my
Wi-Fi yeah this is gonna be like a 45
part series
yeah looking that way I have something
to confess what I've never done a haul
video before I've never done one either
you've never done a haul video oh I
thought that was like a thing but like I
think the beauty guru is doing we got
this VGA cable oh this power strip okay
this is awkward
okay let's just put hard drive this is
great we've had this for like two months
it's been several months and I just like
would open it up and I'm looking at it
like oh you're beautiful 10 terabytes
these are iron wolf pros so the pro
means that you get a five-year warranty
five years of data recovery service
included with the drive and they're
rated for large installations like this
where all these drives are spinning and
vibrating next to each other yeah can be
run 24/7 leather
spoken from awake yeah I think it's okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're uh it's
a bug there's a bird beam the smoke was
coming up through the thing I assumed
this was like a plastic something and it
was it's a bird bug you fried a bug with
your light news about this the things
that have happened today are just like
it's unbelievable and I mean of course
this would be something that decided
yeah it and now I got to clean this be
out of my light because I want to be
real lit oh my gosh I can't believe I
like my front fire in those houses from
a bee
okay let's go god i hate bugs I hate it
oh god he's so crispy oh well body is
fried he is like a Kentucky Fried I
think we are look at this wow I mean he
is in pieces
Wow cut might be empty probably not a
lot of flavor left in a minute okay
electrical tape on here like is this
expose where yes this is not safe that's
why I thought that this is gonna catch
on fire line is never coming back I did
make a joke about you burning my house
down earlier this is why I flew out to
make sure but it all about assembled yet
guys he got on a plane and flew here
just for this just for this that's
pretty amazing only reason I'm here
that was pretty much it
we're legit ready to just plug this in
oh and do a quick test oh I forgot how
much happier these things get little
prize I bet oh you want to do the honors
yes yes yes barb on right on
okay you ready Wow whee so that's it now
we get to change a couple more settings
so I'm just gonna go into global share
settings so included discs all excluded
discs none that's the part where I like
hope everything I did it's okay it works
here we go there it is what did it
really yes
[Music]
so I'm gonna show you a cool trick we
don't actually have to just guess here
so you can see these two I just plugged
into random ports on the patch panel
here can plug in another one lights up
we might Dimity yeah let's go fire it up
we can plug in now we can fire it up
that was the whole thing you just got
served I did this is amazing well thank
you so much this is honestly like the
coolest thing ever like I'm so excited
wow I learned so much about my house
about servers about life
fires this is it you can go connect to
it from any machine in your house boom
this is incredible guys I am so excited
about this make sure you go check out
Linus's channel and subscribe and please
go on comment on every one of his videos
thank you for saving Justine's life on a
huge thank you to 45 drives and seeking
in Kingston and everybody who made this
a possibility because I'm so happy
so that's it we're done bye everybody
hey Siri play back that thing up and
copyright strike for my channel peace
out gotta go back my bang
[Music]
[Applause]